we start today with the humiliatingly
abortive presidential campaign
announcement of Republican Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis this event was a
global humiliation and if DeSantis
presidential campaign is going to follow
the theme and tone and competence of
yesterday's Twitter spaces announcement
it is going to be a very very
short-lived campaign now let's not judge
it all by the first 24 hours but it was
really bad for those of you who don't
know there was an announcement made two
days ago that Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis after much speculation would
indeed announce that he is running for
president in the Republican Party
against Donald Trump and Tim Scott and
Nikki Haley and Vivek ramaswamy and he
would be making this announcement
alongside Elon Musk on Twitter spaces
Twitter spaces is a very rudimentary I
mean we're talking about audio over the
Internet this isn't the most advanced
you know 4K live streaming video you
could imagine so low energy nearly a
dozen technical disasters I'm starting
to think prayer may work because I was
willing technical disasters into
existence all day yesterday and they
happen so I have to reconsider maybe
thoughts and prayers actually do have an
impact I'm kidding of course this was
the worst and most embarrassing
presidential campaign launch that I can
remember
in the modern political era minutes of
silence random throat clearing muffled
commentary from Elon Musk about how the
servers are melting down DeSantis
himself getting booted off of the event
let's just listen to a little bit of and
again I'm there are going to be extended
silences here I'm trying to get
everybody back in the mode of
understanding the environment yesterday
which we live streamed and just
everything going wrong let's jump into
it
it is now live okay so it's starting
about eight minutes late and this is the
sort of thing that we experienced
32 000 people are
all right great so let's see
crashing huh
yeah I think we've got
a just a massive number of people online
so it's um service restraining somewhat
um it's not clear they know they're live
right now that's Elon Musk by the way
speaking
details it's shocking to me they didn't
bring in Mike pillows cyber guides to
help
mm-hmm
take it all in my friends take it all in
normally this this the David Pacman show
doesn't include such extended silences
but the the content is the silence in
this particular case
they seem to have no idea that this is
all live
okay it got even worse if you can
believe it when they sort of like got
closer to actually starting
let's see so here we go yeah I think so
um just to simplify that
so then they cut out
when they seem to realize they were
going to be starting they cut out again
this went on for about half hour
I think we're just gonna use your
as you can see it's just not good
okay and then there were like audio
feedback loops and all sorts of things
now there are we're going to get to the
DeSantis speech in a moment
there are people like Ben Shapiro
right-wing columnist uh commentator Ben
Shapiro saying things like what he
tweeted quote tonight was a perfect
encapsulation of the campaign if you're
obsessed with the Optics of the Twitter
spaces glitch then you're probably not
going to vote DeSantis if you're
interested in political substance
DeSantis is likely your candidate there
were also people on the right saying
this isn't a disaster this event was so
popular that it crashed Twitter servers
so many people were interested that it
crashed Twitter servers it is a big
success all of these narratives are
idiotically wrong first and foremost
once DeSantis started speaking it got
even worse he read a prepared speech
with absolutely no Charisma or
engaging inflection or delivery which
just talked about woke and he whined so
once DeSantis started speaking there was
no substance it was just grievances in
an even whinier voice than the one
Donald Trump speaks in and for this
entire like it wasn't a disaster so many
people were interested that it crashed
the servers this is a success number one
not even a million people this was
promoted for 30 hours everywhere
nationally every play Fox was talking
about it CNN MSNBC every newspaper
everybody was talking about this
and they scrounge together at its peak
900 000 people that's not exactly a
rousing success and the whole story
about Elon musk's takeover of Twitter is
he's the tech guy he's going to rebuild
the stack remember that we're going to
rebuild the stack completely from the
ground up we've we've gotten rid of all
of the Superfluous Engineers now Twitter
is operating beautifully this is just
audio over the Internet it's not even
video and they couldn't hold it together
so the it was such a success that it
crashed is not a viable line now
DeSantis eventually did start speaking
and he somehow figured out a way to be
even more whiny than Trump during his
campaign launch which is really Bonker
stuff he used the word woke I think more
than 20 times I lost count our live
audience lost count here's sort of what
the the speech sounded like Biden's
allowed woke ideology to drive his
agenda we will never surrender to the
woke mob and we will leave woke ideology
in the Dustbin of history there you go
so woke woke you know it remember when
Rudy Giuliani was uh 911 noun verb Ron
DeSantis is woke noun verb that's what
that's what it is a humiliation for Elon
Musk that cannot be understated nothing
worked and once DeSantis actually got to
speak it was the lowest energy campaign
announcement I could imagine
the political Alliance also shouldn't be
ignored Elon Musk who says his number
one priority in buying Twitter and
making the changes to Twitter that he
made is Free Speech
and he's making a big show of
celebrating Ron DeSantis who is quite
literally Banning books in school
libraries and suppressing the speech of
teachers and corporations in Florida
that's the alliance that we have here
this event was so bad even Donald Trump
looked clever and funny in trolling
DeSantis and I want to talk about that
next you all know my feelings about
Donald Trump I think he's a complete and
total doofus dangerous wannabe
authoritarian dictator liar con man
grifter you all know that
the DeSantis campaign launch was so bad
that it made Donald Trump's memes and
posts to truth social
actually make Trump seem like a funny
and clever guy and a couple people wrote
to me and said wow your brain is so
broken David that now you think Trump
looks good you know the same people who
are saying you're too critical of trump
you're you have Trump derangement
syndrome are now telling me I'm deranged
because I think that the DeSantis event
made Trump look better Trump's campaign
now looks like it is functioning
properly that's how bad the DeSantis
launch was Trump posted this video to
Troth Central and it's a contrasting
video of Trump's launch and the DeSantis
launch it's genuinely funny take a look
at this take a listen to this and you'll
see when you hear the country song
it's Trump's campaign launch and then
when you hear audio feedback loops it's
the DeSantis Twitter spaces launch this
is genuinely funny
here we go
[Applause]
we are kind of melting the servers
put his money his mouth
[Music]
Governor Sanders uh make this uh
okay so what is amazing about this is
there are levels of things there are
levels of disasters when we many of us a
couple a few 20 000 of us or so watch
the Trump campaign announcement together
we did a live stream Beautiful live
stream some say the best
and when Trump comes out and he's all
stiff and he's standing there hinging
back and forth and leaning forward and
God bless the USA is playing and a crowd
of Mar-A-Lago sycophants is almost you
know peeing their pants and in
titillated pleasure over the presence of
Donald Trump we look at it and we say
this is a humiliation how it after all
these years dating back to 2015 this
disastrous Trump campaign all this stuff
how are these people this is this is
humiliating and Trump looks like a more
what could possibly be worse than this
and then what's worse is DeSantis tries
to announce his candidacy on Twitter
spaces and it goes horribly wrong by the
time it starts 25 minutes late due to a
technical disaster DeSantis just talks
about woke woke woke reading a prepared
speech on Twitter and you realize wow
the Trump event was the previous bottom
of the barrel but DeSantis is far far
far far worse and now we go well the
Trump event I guess wasn't that bad now
meanwhile over on Truth social Trump
really getting a lot of mileage out of
this and it'll be interesting to see
where the polling goes as a result of
this Fiasco Trump posting to truth quote
Rob my red button so he calls Ron
DeSantis Rob now I don't even know where
that comes from Rob my red button is
bigger better stronger and is working
truth yours does not per my conversation
with Kim Jong-un of North Korea soon to
become my friend then continuing wow the
de Sanctus Twitter launch is a disaster
his whole campaign will be a disaster
watch Trump continuing this genuinely is
funny uh Tim Scott's presidential launch
even with the broken micro phone don't
pay the contractor Tim was by far the
best presidential launch of the week
robs was a catastrophe and then lastly
Trump trophing is the DeSantis launch
fatal yes so a self-inflicted error for
sure
later on in the evening desant
disappeared on Fox News to talk policy
and that was a disaster we'll talk later
but but but but before we assume too
much
DeSantis continues to gain in the polls
against Trump
since news of the announcement broke
what you see on the screen the purple
line is Trump and the green line is
DeSantis as you can see starting in late
March when news of Trump's arrest went
public it was just up up up for Trump
going from 44 to 56 in the Republican
primary and DeSantis falling from a high
of 30 all the way down to 19. but
but since news broke that DeSantis would
be announcing DeSantis climbing from 19
to 21 and Trump dropping from 56 to 54.
is it a big change no
but is it an inflection point is Maga
going to abandon Trump are we going to
see this is the inevitable rise of Ron
DeSantis we have to wait and see after
the break we will look at desantis's
first major interview as a 2024
presidential candidate and I will warn
you it is tough to watch remember that
Monday Memorial Day now just a few days
away we will be offering a one-day
membership special this is our end of
May launch 2024
discounted membership special one day
only if you'd like to be notified of how
to sign up for a criminally inexpensive
membership on Monday
simply get on my newsletter at
davidpackman.com we'll take a quick
break it is a hell of a program today
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
so after his completely farcical
presidential announcement on Twitter
spaces uh Florida Republican Governor
Ron DeSantis gave his first interview as
a presidential candidate he gave this
interview to Trey Gowdy who was guest
hosting on Fox News and DeSantis
suffered what I call a talking point
coma he couldn't stop repeating the word
woke he also threw in an anti-semitic
conspiracy theory for good measure right
I mean he is running as a republican
after all let's take a look at this and
this is just if you thought the
announcement was bad when DeSantis
actually gets a chance to speak it gets
even worse so let's start there here is
Ron DeSantis with a talking point coma
can't stop saying woke well first of all
the woke mind virus is basically a form
of cultural Marxism at the end of the
day it's an attack on the truth and
because it's a war on truth I think we
have no choice but to wage a war on woke
so how does that I work for a president
some of it may be the bully pulpit being
willing to tell the truth and not being
deluded by ideology which we see in many
aspects of our society there you go so
woke woke woke Florida is where woke
goes to die we will end woke so please
understand that the term cultural
Marxism is nothing but a far right wing
conspiracy theory that is let me to to
put it lightly often tinged with
anti-Semitism I I get emails every time
one of these right winger starts talking
about cultural Marxism people write in
say David what the hell I know Marxism
the economic theory what on Earth is
cultural Marxism when the right uses the
term cultural Marxism they are talking
about a supposed leftist agenda that
wants to undermine Traditional Values it
wants to erode societal Norms it wants
to promote political correctness and
police police speech and this sort of
thing often what they accuse George
Soros of is tantamount to the very
cultural Marxism they claim exists and
they say that this so-called cultural
Marxism is a conspiracy propagated by
left-wing intellectuals left-wing
activists Democrats
Etc they want to infiltrate and control
institutions including Academia media
entertainment and they want to reshape
culture to fit their ideology now
according to that perspective
cultural marxists are accused of
manipulating language promoting and
using identity politics advocating for
social justice issues and LGBT rights
and so on and so forth at the expense of
individual freedoms and Liberty and so
on and so forth the most important thing
to understand about so-called cultural
Marxism is that it essentially does not
exist and what I mean by that is
Marxism focuses on economic structures
and class struggle that's the first
thing to understand it doesn't actually
focus on cultural or social issues
although Marxism does acknowledge that
culture and Society will be shaped by
the economic system that's number one so
even the term doesn't really make sense
secondly the entire emergence of the
term cultural Marxism came from a
misinterpretation of actual Marxism
that's number two and then number three
there's also no marxists in the United
States now I know you might go to uh you
know the local Magic the Gathering
tournament and meet an actual Marxist
who understands Marxist ideology and
says they subscribe to it and I'm not
insulting Magic the Gathering I'm just
saying you might be able to find someone
somewhere who's actually a Marxist there
is not a single Marxist in a position of
power in federal government that I can
think of in the United States so when
the right talks about cultural Marxism
they don't even really know what they're
talking about it's not Marxism it
doesn't exist and it's thinly veiled
anti-Semitism so but that wasn't the
worst moment of this entire thing then
DeSantis is asked
what makes you different than Trump when
Nikki Haley was asked this question she
said I'm a woman of color and I'm
younger
when Tim Scott was asked what makes you
different from Trump he didn't even
really answer and he said there will be
a stark contrast by which I guess he
means he's younger than Trump and he's
black
does Ron DeSantis actually answer the
question let's see yeah so why now and
what distinguishes you from from the
other candidates are there policy
differences or is it more about
electability and how you would Implement
those policies even if you agree on them
I don't know
well why now I think it's because the
country's going in the wrong direction
we have another four years of the Biden
Administration I think some of the
damage is going to be irreversible I
think we have an opportunity now kind of
like the late 1970s when Jimmy Carter
was President uh to really move the
country in a much stronger Direction and
really bring a lot of bold leadership to
Bear uh why me well I think what we've
been able to do in Florida is two things
one we've had unprecedented policy
success all the things that we believe
as Republicans or as conservatives for
many many years we've been able to take
those values and those principles and
actually turn them into reality every
single day we put up big wins on the
board but we're doing that while also
enjoying major political success you
alluded to it we were able to win
re-election by a historical margin so as
you can see he doesn't actually say what
distinguishes him from Trump when he was
asked about the military
and exactly what he would do with
Ukraine he talked about gender ideology
I'm not kidding guys I'm not kidding
look at this
all right you uh wore the uniform if you
are elected president you may be the
first one in a while uh to have worn the
uniform how would you address the
ongoing war in Eastern Europe between
Russia and Ukraine on day one of the
scientist presidents good question
well first I think what we need to do as
a veteran is recognize that our military
has become politicized uh you talk about
gender ideology you talk about things
like global warming that they're somehow
concerned and that's not the military
that I served in we need to return our
military to focusing on uh commitment
focusing on the core values and the core
Mission wow that would be something that
I could take care of on day one uh
there'll be a new sheriff in town as
commander-in-chief and I think you'll
see recruiting start to get back to
where it needs to be because people
don't want to join award as if the
military is not big enough military and
I think it's been really really
problematic look in terms of what's
going on over in Eastern Europe
um you know I'd like to see a settlement
of this I do not want to see a wider War
okay so what he would do is he would he
wants the war to end is what he would do
but woke in the military is really the
problem
disastrous interview is that going to
convince Mega voters to switch to
DeSantis from Trump let's give it a few
days and see where the polling lands a
wildly triggered failed former president
Donald Trump even before Ron DeSantis
announced that he was running for
president released an attack ad on Ron
DeSantis calling him a swamp creature
let's take a look at this this might
give us a little bit of a preview of the
sorts of lines of attack that we may be
seeing during what is certainly going to
be an extremely ugly Republican primary
campaign take a look
Trump defeats the
2016. president Trump defeats the
Liberals and heads to Washington to
train the swamp but swamp creature Ron
DeSantis is about to start his third
term in Congress and he's already voted
repeatedly to cut Social Security and
Medicare
2017. Trump passes huge tax cuts for
nearly everyone and Ron DeSantis he's
pushing a bill that would swap those tax
cuts for a new 23 national sales tax so
let's just pick pick this new families
pay more just to pick I can't fact check
everything here but Trump has been
saying this a lot that Ron DeSantis was
going to put in a 23 sales tax and and
you know uh make everybody pay more the
reality is what DeSantis supported was
part of the fair tax proposal and what
that would have done is put in a 23
percent national sales tax but get rid
of income taxes payroll taxes estate
taxes and gift taxes and the idea was
simplify the tax code and make it more
transparent by lowering taxes for rich
people so is it a lie to say descent is
supported a 23 national sales tax it's
not a lie but it was a right-wing
proposal to lower taxes on the rich
imagine that you're in the 37 federal
tax bracket and then you've got
uh your Social Security Medicare and so
on and so forth
if you replace all of that stuff if you
get rid of income tax payroll tax estate
tax and gift tax and you just pay 23
percent that's a ma on what you spend
that's an insane decline in taxes on the
rich so like is it a lie what Trump is
saying in the ad it's not a lie but it's
extraordinarily deceptive
. Trump is building a wall securing the
Border fighting The Invasion while Ron
DeSantis is voting against funding for
Trump's wall in Washington one was a
leader and one let us down even DeSantis
admitted there are big differences
between him and Trump obviously there is
because I voted contrary to him
so this is going to be such an ugly
primary that it's going to make your
head spin but also a factor will be that
Trump is constantly lying about DeSantis
and if DeSantis decides to acknowledge
that Trump is running right because so
far it's been like just don't even talk
about Trump
is he going to tell the truth about
Trump policy or is he going to have to
lie to draw distinctions that don't
really exist we're going to watch it
many different right-wing media outlets
and right-wing elected officials
slamming Ron DeSantis decision to
announce his presidential campaign on
Twitter one such critique uh or uh
ridicule came from Fox and Friends Fox
and Friends with a what the heck is
Twitter space's moment ridiculing
DeSantis for his choice here hey Lucas
so he's going to make the big
announcement with Elon Musk at six
o'clock tonight on Twitter spaces
what the heck is Twitter spaces
I wish I knew more basketball
I think he's trying to make it sounds
like a video function yeah right yeah
someone's streaming
using social media as a way to announce
a presidency yes it's all very
fascinating so listen there's people
wrote to me and said you know David it's
weird because yesterday morning Fox and
Friends was just gushing about how great
Tim Scott is and now they're making fun
of Ron DeSantis what are the
explanations there's two primary
interpretations of this one
interpretation is that fox sees DeSantis
as the only guy that might defeat Trump
so they attack him and praised Tim Scott
who doesn't have a shot all in reality
in service to helping Trump you attack
the only guy that might beat Trump you
kind of pretend to prop up guys that
have no shot like Tim Scott and it just
keeps Trump at the front that's one
interpretation of what fox fox from
friends is doing second interpretation
is they genuinely want someone other
than Trump but for whatever reason the
brass at Fox News has decided DeSantis
is not the guy we want so we're gonna
make fun of DeSantis and and praised him
Scott uh we we absolutely have no idea
at this point in time Fox News is
priority really
is maintain access to those in power and
that is going to be their primary
motivation we will see in the next
couple of weeks how Fox news's
perspective on the primary solidifies in
the meantime Marjorie Taylor green is
becoming Donald Trump's latest attack
dog against Ron DeSantis yesterday I
told you about Kerry Lake going after
DeSantis in service of trump now it is
Marjorie Taylor green what Carrie Lake
and Marjorie Taylor green have in common
um is they both seem to be openly vying
to be Donald Trump's vice presidential
choices here's Marjorie Taylor green
also attacking DeSantis for where he is
announcing his campaign which he did
last night on Twitter spaces you don't
announce that you're running for for
president of the United States
in some kind of little Twitter world
it's not a real world Twitter is not
real so I can't comprehend why that
would be the place to do the
announcement it makes no sense it's not
serious okay so Marjorie Taylor green
says DeSantis isn't serious remember
that there are there is the belief that
Trump will pick a woman to be his
running mate this time around the four
women whose names are being floated are
Marjorie Taylor green Kerry Lake Nikki
Haley who's running against Trump and
Christy gnome from South Dakota who it's
not even clear if she's interested and
it's not even really clear if she's the
top Contender so arguably Marjorie
Taylor green participating in this in
service to supporting her own potential
candidacy to be Donald Trump's vice
president a wild 24 hours all of these
clips will be on our Instagram which you
can find by searching Instagram for
David packman show they'll be on our
Tick Tock and they will be on our you
YouTube channel as well
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show today
we're going to be speaking with David
Auerbach who's a writer and technologist
and author of Mega Nets how digital
forces beyond our control
commandeer our daily lives and inner
realities maybe to start with David when
we talk about Mega Nets what what do you
mean by Mega Nets what are some examples
yeah I think the other question you want
to ask is why a new word and the key
aspect is that I wanted a term that not
only includes these huge networks uh by
which I include everything from social
networks to online games to
cryptocurrencies
um but to emphasize that the people and
the data we put into these networks are
now an intrinsic part of it that we're
accustomed to thinking of these networks
as things that we program that Engineers
program and come up with and and we're
just subjected to them but that's not
really what's happening what's happening
is we have these systems that now are
engaged in feedback loops very high high
volume high velocity and uh High
virality feedback loops that constantly
cause their own algorithms and behavior
to change so that you can't step into
the same algorithm twice so to speak
and my argument that I make in the book
is that these particular kinds of
systems which I call Mega Nets
um don't
let us have control in the way that we
think we use it we in the way that we
think we do or the way that we used to
over software that in fact they are
becoming more akin to Natural systems
like you know the weather or plate
tectonics or even something like
macroeconomics where you can exert some
push on it but asking say to okay let's
just stamp out everything bad on the
Internet is like saying well let's just
Stamp Out All stock crashes yeah when we
um uh when we think about some of those
feedback loops and algorithms I mean
just to take something simple like much
of the social media we interact with I
think in in passing casual layperson
terms many of us sort of understand that
these algorithms are optimized for
keeping us on the platform as well as
generating engagement and that
engagement is more likely to be
generated by content that triggers a
bigger emotional reaction and so that
that's where we get a lot of these Echo
chambers of extremist content and things
that titillate and so on and so forth we
kind of think we have this passing
understanding sort of of what's
happening but there's more to it right
and I think this is part of what you get
to in the book that there's a whole
other layer that goes beyond that
understanding
yeah because what happens is that
um you know that focus on engagement
certainly there's a financial incentive
there but some of it is also that
um these algorithms are effectively run
out of control it's not as though
someone at Facebook is making the choice
for engagement every single time the
algorithms are being tweaked and shunted
so that you know often based on wrong
information even because you know there
are no way infallible what you get is
um is our our forces that uh that that
do amplify popular content but also
forces that cause uh balkanization and
mutual incomprehension uh simply because
yeah there is that catering towards
what's termed engagement and the focus
on engagement isn't I mean yes profit is
there but it's also well what would you
substitute for it because at that point
well now the uh now the tech companies
are telling you what you want engagement
sort of became the default uh the
default rationale for what to show
people because anything else is okay the
tech companies are now running our lives
so if Facebook puts a you know a warning
on a piece of content saying this is
misinformation well okay that's not
optimizing for engagement but you've
caused a different problem at that point
there are many um yeah no go ahead
yeah the issue is that even if you were
to have to be able to make those sorts
of decisions in a way that wouldn't
cause massive uh controversy you still
have the issue that there's more content
that can be possibly be filtered
certainly ahead of time you're
constantly closing the Barn Door after
the horse is bolted and that's why when
misinformation by one cent or another
gets out it's very hard to change
people's minds because the nature of
these Mega Nets is that you can now find
reinforcing data for whatever Viewpoint
you have and that's really what's
changed is that you have these
many-to-many networks and it's not even
a matter of killing brush fires so much
is that it's creating once you have a
surplus of content and no evolutionary
pressure to to sort of select one
narrative that everybody then sort of
falls into then there's there's no Force
driving people to reconcile and you know
you can't
do much to to to bring people together
around a an enforced narrative so along
those lines you know often the idea of
we need more regulation is thrown around
and whether folks even know what they
really mean by that when they say it
isn't totally clear sometimes there's a
sort of these companies have gotten too
big and they need to be broken up and
that will improve the situation but it's
not exactly totally clear how Jonathan
height has mentioned like one thing that
would be useful at the individual user
level would be uh you can't be anonymous
to the platform you can use a handle
that's not your real name but you should
genuinely have to sort of like register
with the social media platform so they
know who you are but a lot of people are
like I don't know that I necessarily
want every social media platform having
my driver's license I don't know some of
the things you suggest are kind of
counter-intuitive can you talk a little
bit about what you think would help
yeah well I think that you know one of
the reasons why people are having such a
hard time coming with fixes is that we
don't understand the problem that well
we don't understand the limits of our
control that if if you're going to
regulate the first impulses to say okay
just like get rid of everything I don't
like
and
um and it's put the tech companies into
a weird position because they are they
do is more or less safe now and again
that they literally don't have the
amount of control that they that we
think they do and that they often claim
to because you know there's a there's
this Facebook memo where they they're
more concerned about being uh seen as
not having control of their own systems
that is being perceived as evil like
better that they'd be evil capitalists
and that they literally be out of
control but unfortunately the latter one
is a lot closer true so my suggestions
are you know I guess they're they're
meant to
um try to sort of break up the
Tendencies of these Mega Nets by uh uh
by by decoagulating the pockets that
tend to amplify stuff and what I have in
mind here you know in the run-up to the
2020 election Facebook banned all
political advertising right that's not
the action of a company that can like
you know make a fine-grained filtering
of content so I take that as admission
there okay now there's no question that
did uh that I'm sure that did have an
effect
um uh was it over the top Maybe
but uh it's that sort of level that we
actually can't operate on and the
question is how do you do those sorts of
interventions without it uh interfering
in people's freedoms and without it
um and without it coming off as biased
so that's why I advocate for
non-targeted mechanisms where you aren't
really trying to Target a particular
type of content Because unless it's
something really extreme like child
pornography that's okay to Target I
think we all agree that that stuff can
be removed from the net but when it
comes to you know sort of stuff that's
uh in the quote-unquote mainstream of
political discourse well the mainstream
now includes pretty much each side
thinking that the other side is evil so
you're not going to win on that one what
you can do instead though is try to
amplify
diversity and
um and the quieter voices in other words
enforce something like turn taking
where basically the louder you get the
less privilege you have to be heard in
the algorithm or say intentionally
randomized recommendation algorithms so
you may get things that are not what's
being recommended to you Tick Tock
apparently did this with uh uh
pro-anorexia videos because they were
recommending two pro-anorexia too many
pro-anorexia videos to that crowd so
they actually broke down the
recommendation algorithm and said okay
start giving them other stuff doesn't
matter what it is just stop giving them
the reiterations of what they already
have and targeting something specific
like a particular type of content means
you're always going to be chasing after
the next one but if you were to be if
you were to do this more generally
speaking and not say look we're not
Banning this we're just going to say
that there's going to be a more you know
egalitarian uh float of what you see and
who gets to speak I think you could move
in a good in a better Direction now that
isn't to say that you would have to not
you have to do experiments here you have
to make sure that it is fair and not
corrupt and all of that but I do think
that those sorts of solutions are more
feasible than the ones we look to now
where effectively we're saying oh just
go in and audit the algorithms and
eliminate bias and you know do what we
want that's life to me is a non-starter
it seems that to some degree a lot of
these discussions that have to be had
about how to fix this problem that we
don't yet 100 understand but we're
hopefully building a picture of what the
problem is it seems a lot of this would
be mitigated by greater media literacy
and critical thinking skills which which
generally speaking seem to be lacking
now I don't want to pretend like that's
just the solution that if people were
smarter because you're sort of saying
like all these stupid people are making
us have to figure out this sort of thing
I I don't want to say that but at the
same time when I see in my space some of
the narratives that end up having to be
fought and that then you have to figure
out policy on or they lead to what some
then say is censorship or whatever if we
had on average
greater critical thinking in media
literacy skills it seems as though that
would be useful even though I don't want
to just say the problem is stupid people
it's interesting I mean from my
perspective I mean maybe I was one of
the stupid people because a lot of the
stuff wasn't on obvious to me and one of
the things I talk about in the book is
you know I I worked at Google I was a
software engineer in the early days and
I don't think any of us anticipated the
degree of impact that people would have
that the users would have
um it just it just it was just not an
obvious thing we were so used to saying
okay well here's the data and we do
stuff with it not oh users are coming in
and they're shaping the algorithms so I
I think part of the problem is is that
um
is that even very smart people you know
it's not an obvious system
um and I don't claim to understand at
all and it took you know it took quite a
bit of thinking for me to sort of get my
head around what I thought was actually
going on because even the really smart
people I knew seem to be falling into
various cul-de-sacs uh partly I think as
an effect of being reinforced in this or
that thought by being by getting placed
into these little balkanized uh uh
they're not they're not just bubbles
they're like narrative bunkers where the
assumptions become so
taken for granted that you can never get
past them so I actually I'm not I think
that the level of thinking required is
actually beyond that which individuals
can easily get a hold of because I mean
I had I had I had a lot of time to do it
and I still I still am not certain about
it that and one of the points I make is
that there's just too much that this
explosion of data and information I
think is moving the unit of agency
higher so that individual rationality
doesn't work and doesn't have the same
efficacy that it used to a gang is gonna
a gang of people a group of people is
going to be able to out out shout in
these networks any individual no matter
what their
um no matter how how great their
um their
uh their critical thinking may be there
are exceptions you know if you're Donald
Trump obviously you have more pull if
you're Jeffrey Hinton you know one of
the founders of deep learning as it
exists today you know that that will
count for something but in the main I
think
um
the application of critical thinking I
think it leads to a sense of of
powerlessness and of uncertainty of
flip-flopping between well
uh there's that there's those groups of
people over there that literally don't
even have the same language or
foundations for their thought that I do
how on Earth do I even resolve that that
it's sort of it's it's super rational in
that in that
um it's too big for one person or even a
company to get its uh to get its head
around and I don't mean to be fatalistic
about that but you know it echoes the
current concerns with AI that you know
AI is not intelligent per se but it does
have a capacity to
incorporate these huge amounts of data
in the way that we don't and that's one
of the reasons why we can't exactly tell
what's going on with it and I mean even
again very look at they're very smart
people who I think are completely wrong
about what AI is capable of or what it
does you know to me these new chat Bots
they do not think they do not understand
what they're saying to me I think that
is absolutely
um indisputable but
um you know there are people with more
expertise in it than I do that insist
that that's not the case and I don't
think any amount of critical thinking is
going to resolve that you need something
that's sort of like structurally just
prevents chaos from forming last thing I
want to ask you about do you have an
opinion about and if you don't that's
fine what's been going on with Twitter
recently uh DeSantis launch failure
aside in terms of you know I have found
that even though I didn't I at no point
have decided I'm sick of Twitter and I'm
getting off of it but slowly since Elon
Musk took over you know they took away
my and many other people's verification
and um we're now looking at my verified
feed does nothing for me it shows me
people with 30 followers who are paying
eight bucks a month for some reason and
how all power to them but that's not the
way I was using that before that was a
useful tool for me the for you feed is
even though I I'm a person on the left
it's feeding me right wing stuff from
Bridget Gabriel and other right-wing
bomb throwers so that's not interesting
to me my following feed where I see the
people I'm actually following
is quite dead because many of those
people also have reduced their usage of
Twitter what do you have an opinion
about what's happening on Twitter
um I mean not an informed one since I
don't have a huge I don't have much in
the way of sources on the inside but
um I think it's a combination of intent
and incompetence I mean you know
um even even if they were even if they
supposedly fired their worst performing
50 there was still a brain drain there
you know that that that that that
musk's track record is of going in
shaking things up just blowing things up
and then sort of forcing people to
reassemble it
um the problem is is that it's okay if
you do that you know if you do that to a
private company no one no one's going to
notice except the employee and employees
and maybe you know the stock market or
whatever if you do it on Twitter you're
gonna see the theme showing so for any
of these
phenomena that you're talking about some
of them may be uh partly or wholly
intentional but I have no doubt that a
lot of it is just sheer chaos that
they're they're struggling you know he
brought in
um uh he brought in uh that assistant
who slept on the floor she was gone a
month later yeah uh and it sounds like
you know I I the his new CEO appointment
seems like a a scapegoat to me so uh so
um if you have a more specific question
I can say but I do think that in some
ways Twitter was all always a very
anomalous entity in that it didn't make
it didn't especially make money
um it was run worse because it didn't
make money it was run worse than a lot
of the other big networks
um it was a massive Target because of it
being a Public Square the target for
everybody
and so
um I it was never I don't think it was
ever going to end well it didn't happen
have to end with uh in this particular
way with us buying it but you know there
was a reason why uh there weren't any
competing bids it's it is very much a
poison chalice and in some ways I do
suspect that the very idea of a Central
Public Square is on the way out because
um
it it's time it was becoming basically
impossible for it to keep people happy
enough people happy
um now musk sort of as the
accelerationist option yes very much
Happy we could make people
um you know my my Twitter experiences
I mean it's a I've run into some of the
same problems but
um
I think because of the way I curate my
feed it's probably hit me a little less
but I can I can see the decline
um uh and uh
and again I mean
some of these are definitely bugs and
there's definitely a chance that the
thing I mean I've seen weird bizarre
things popping up and it's like okay
that's got to be a bug I don't get what
that is the fact that we can't totally
tell I guess is an interesting part of
the uh part of the whole thing well the
weird thing is is that I mean that I
think that's always been the case it's
just become much more noticeable yeah
you know I think you know Facebook
thought I was black for many years it
might still
um and if I knew that I could see why
some of the ads I was getting it's like
oh okay that's that's why
um but you know and I'm pretty sure that
wasn't intentional but you know the job
of the company is just to keep it from
becoming too obvious yeah Twitter's
problem right now is that it's become
pretty obvious very much so very much so
the book is Mega Nets how digital forces
beyond our control commandeer our daily
lives and inner realities we've been
speaking with the book's author David
Auerbach David really appreciate your
time and insights today
great okay uh thank you for having me
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
in the midst of all of the hubbub around
Ron DeSantis announcing he's running for
president Tim Scott announcing that he's
running Donald Trump spending 24 to 48
hours simply going after Ron DeSantis
everybody forgot about Nikki Haley Nikki
Haley the former governor of South
Carolina is also running for the
Republican nomination she is getting
absolutely no attention she's desperate
for relevance so what does she do
yesterday
she goes I don't know let me go
completely anti-transgender why not this
seems to be playing well among some now
she's not wrong the biggest Applause
lines for the last couple of years at
right wing events including CPAC and
others have been when speakers make fun
of or go after LGBT people it's a
Resurgence of that in the Republican
party so here is Nikki Haley figuring
out I guess how to get some attention
maybe people will choose her because
she's going to come out against trans
people in a disgusting way here's what
she had to say at politics and eggs in
New Hampshire
we've got
time where is everyone right my daughter
ran track in high school did she I
wouldn't even know how to have that
conversation with her how do we get our
girls comfortable with biological Boys
in their locker room
it's not okay
everybody know about Dylan Mulvaney
Bud Light right right make no mistake
right that is a guy dressed up like a
girl making fun of women women don't act
like that
get everybody's wondering why a third of
our teenage girls
seriously contemplated suicide last year
what are we doing to them we're supposed
to be growing strong girls confident
girls not ones being made fun of right
so one of the reasons that's actually
evidence-based for the increase in
suicidal ideation among particularly
teen girls but teens in general is
unrestricted access to social media
seems to be extremely damaging in many
different ways Cal Newport has a recent
podcast episode on this issue that I
highly recommend people listen to but
the idea among the anti-trans activists
that quote keeping men out of women's
sports that's how they call it we've got
to keep men out of women's sports they
pretend that it's a feminist issue a
women's issue
the claim that banning trans women from
Sports is a feminist issue number one
ignores the history and diversity of
actual feminism feminism feminism isn't
this monolithic movement it's a comp
compilation or combination of different
perspectives and goals that aim to
achieve what different people see as
gender equality and justice and there
are many feminists who support trans
rights and inclusion and they see trans
women as allies in a struggle against
whatever it is that they believe is the
most important thing to struggle against
and so part of the feminist movement
uh argues that when you exclude trans
women from women's spaces and activities
you're actually reinforcing the very
harmful stereotypes that feminism has
sought to undo but it's okay to
acknowledge that the so-called let's not
let's call it trans women in women's
sports to to try to put uh a less
offensive way to describe it that is a
difficult issue for some sports
in which physical Advantage comes from
muscle mass weightlifting would be one
example and I am the first to tell you
that although trans women and women's
sports
is an issue that is a slice of a slice
of a slice right you've got like all
political issues issues related to
gender within issues related to gender
issues that are under the trans category
under trans you have all sorts of
different issues bathrooms and all the
within that you've got okay Sports and
then a subsection of that would be
Sports in which muscle mass confers a
definitive Advantage so we're
understanding the scope right this is
not the biggest issue there are
different opinions about how it should
be handled some say so you know 31
states have gone the way of banning
biological male individuals from women's
sports in some capacity that's one
approach summer taking it's been done in
31 States as of about a year and a half
ago the number may be slightly different
now that's one View
another approach is you let trans women
biological males right the different
people use different terms for this you
allow those individuals to compete in
women's sports if they meet certain
criteria such as undergoing uh hormone
suppression therapy for a certain period
of time as signed off on by a medical
professional the NCAA has gone in that
direction for some sports in some cases
another idea is for the sports in which
muscle mass confers a definitive
Advantage you create a separate category
for Trans athletes who don't fit into
the other binary categories there are
many who say that actually is going to
further stigma that's the last thing we
need the point is there is a
conversation to be had
about trans women
specifically in the sports where muscle
mass is really important Nikki Haley
talking about a guy named Dylan Mulvaney
who's with Bud Light sponsorship is just
disgusting uh pandering to the
anti-trans crowd but nobody's paying
attention to Nikki Haley and her
campaign was Dead on Arrival so she's
struggling for relevance I want to give
you another one of these examples of Fox
News casually mentioning oh that story
we covered for a week and told you that
we verified independently turns out it
was complete and total fake news the
latest is from Maria Bartiromo this is
the story Fox News ran with for a week
last week about supposed homeless
veterans being kicked out of hotels in
order to make room for undocumented
immigrants because of something Biden
did the story was totally made up Maria
bartaromo waited an extra week before
casually updating us that the story was
completely made up we want to update you
on a report last week claiming that
Upstate hotels in Orange and Rockland
counties including the crossroads Hotel
Crossroads Hotel evicted a group of
homeless veterans we've since learned
that veterans Advocates misled local
officials and it now turns out those
eviction claims were false we want to
update you on the story make sure the
record was set straight and we'll get
more to you as we get it yeah there you
go what she means is it's fake news we
reported fake news and angered people
and fired people up based on a story
that's completely imaginary and remember
that Fox News said they verified the
story it's not well listen someone
reported this and we were misled they
claimed to have verified the story and
what it sounds like is going on is Fox
News lawyers have said you might want to
make a some kind of retraction about
this we did talk earlier this week of
Laura Ingram
also casually mentioning by the way that
story was fake I
Eagles could move in turns out the group
behind the claim made it up
we have no clue as to why anyone would
do such a thing no we'll bring you any
updates should they come why would any
as I said on Monday why would anybody
lie in order to try to support their
pre-existing political narratives that
Biden is treating undocumented
immigrants quote better than Americans
and Veterans why would why would anyone
make that up and this was one other
retraction that was issued quick update
on a story from earlier this week about
homeless veterans being displaced from a
hotel in Newburgh New York right to make
room for migrants we're now looking into
new reports that a veterans Advocate
misled lawmakers about or and media
Outlets about a story that some homeless
men may have been hired to pose as
veterans we've reached out to the
organization for a statement but so far
have not heard back it's all so hazy we
just don't know what happened so there
is Maria Bartiromo shamelessly joining
those who say listen I don't know we
were misled wait you said you verified
the story that they don't mention
anymore
completely and totally pathetic we'll
see if any more retractions are coming
we have such a great bonus show for you
today that I hope that you're already a
member oh the bonus show where you want
to make money yeah everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad we
will discuss us on today's bonus show
the new study that finds 2 billion
people could be impacted by
life-threatening Heat by the end of the
century we've talked about heat before
and I don't mean Trump talking about
applying light and heat to cure I'm
talking about heat and uh climate change
and the issues that it will bring
forward this new study is very specific
about where these dangerous heat levels
will be secondly in Texas they are
allowing unlicensed religious chaplains
to quote counsel students as if they
were therapists but they are not this is
the latest
placating of the uh religious
I don't even what to call you know what
to call them the sort of Christian
Sharia type folks in Texas we will
discuss it and U.S colleges are now
exploring
what would admissions look like if they
were no longer race conscious which is
we're talking about affirmative action
here this would be a major change in
American college admissions what would
it mean what would it do what would the
implications be all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show can't wait
for you to join us by simply signing up
at joinpakman.com
foreign